[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv et 78 et merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette première édition du
7 8 politique et de la saison 7 8
politique dédiée ce mois ci au premier
tour de l'élection législative partielle
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
élections qui se tiendra les 20 et 27
septembre les candidates et candidats
engagés vont débattre dans quelques
instants durant une heure et demie
vous allez voir la liste des onze
candidatures validées par la préfecture
ont ce postulant au poste de député pour
remplacer nadia est démissionnaire suite
à sa nomination au gouvernement en juin
dernier
à noter que la démission de la
représentante de la république en marche
a permis d'éviter la prise de fonctions
de son suppléant actuellement mis en
examen dans le cadre d'une affaire de
trafic de stupéfiants au niveau
international neuf candidats devraient
être en ligne avec nous pour ce débat
nous avons eu un soucis de connexion
avec l'un d'entre eux laurent cochon
pour lui prl néanmoins sept autres sont
déjà avec nous philippe benassaya lui
maire de bois d'arcy candidats aient
l'air nous rejoindra dans une vingtaine
de minutes
voilà pour la petite précision et pour
les présentations olivier égalant
candidats debout à la france un
mouvement dont vous êtes le délégué dans
la 11e circonscription
bonjour à vous merci laurent morin
également responsable du rassemblement
national dans les yvelines ancien
premier adjoint de cyril notamment que
la ville lors du mandat précédent
bonsoir bienvenue pierre lui ce
représentant de la république en marche
dans les yvelines
bonjour également bonsoir kamal ben
marouf du collectif république par
raison également candidat est avec nous
bonjour également patrick plan que
candidat de lutte ouvrière
sandrine grands comme première adjointe
à trappes sous les couleurs de
génération vous êtes conseillère
régionale également et vous avez le
soutien d'europe écologie verts dans ce
scrutin et thibaut langlois qui
représente valérie froberger vous êtes
son suppléant elle ne peut pas être avec
nous aujourd'hui je précise que la
candidate et tête de soignante aussi à
l'hôpital de garches et qu'ensemble vous
portez l'alliance pcf
elle est fille au cours de ce scrutin
bonjour voila ça m'a permis de tester un
peu les connexions et d'entendre les uns
et les autres vous l'avez compris pour
ce débat ne seront pas
ils ne sont pas présents physiquement
les candidats crise de sanitaires et
gestes barrières oblige néanmoins les
mêmes règles elle s'applique et le temps
de parole est chronométrée est la
première prise de parole se fera selon
l'ordre enregistrée en préfecture à
olivier galon va donc commencer avec
vous en quelques mots rapidement quel
est l'enjeu du scrutin un scrutin je le
précise qui concerne les habitants de
bois d'arcy elancourt fontenay le fleury
la verrière le mesnil saint denis saint
cyr l'école ou encore trappe les
communes de la 11e les enjeux selon vous
les enjeux c'est de permettre à nos à
nos concitoyens de s'exprimer pour
croiser deux types de personnes quand on
va discuter avec eux certains disent je
ne crois plus en la politique
d'autres disent les politiciens ne nous
écoute plus on a beau envoyer des
lettres des lettres il ne se passe rien
de notre démarche et c'est d'aller voir
les genres poursuivant ce premier tour
de table avec laurent morin responsable
du rassemblement national dans les
yvelines le scrutin les enjeux selon
vous eh bien écoutez moi je vois deux
enjeux très clair lors de ce scrutin un
enjeu politique est un jeu démocratique
le croit mort un jeu politique les
électeurs ont l'opportunité d'envoyer un
message fort à ceux qui nous gouvernent
depuis des décennies et qui ont échoué
s'il le décide les électeurs ont en
effet la possibilité de rejeter les
candidats qui représente dans cette
élection les partis qui ont amené la
france à l'effondrement que nous vivons
actuellement les politiques mises
successivement en place par les
républicains par la république manches
par le parti socialiste ont été
absolument dévastée rasta trice nous en
payons le prix aujourd'hui
le deuxième enjeu l'enjeu démocratique
c'est celui de la participation les
électeurs ont un choix importants à
faire celui de désigner leurs
représentants à l'assemblée nationale et
j'aimerais dire une chose au aux
abstentionnistes que je comprends qu'il
puisse être totalement désabusé que je
comprends que les préoccupations
quotidiennes puisse absorber toute leur
énergie et qu'ils finissent par décider
de ne plus se mobiliser pour certains
scrutins j'aurais pu au moins une faire
le même choix il ya une dizaine
année mais je crois que si l'on se
saisit si l'on ne se saisit pas de la
politique alors la politique finit par
se saisir de vous et je crois qu'avec la
crise sanitaire nous avons eu un exemple
flagrant de certaines décisions qui ont
été prises ou non et qui ont eu des
conséquences sur sur un certain nombre
de deux français sur un certain nombre
de familles donc voilà pour moi les deux
enjeux et on parlera de cette thématique
là notamment de la crise sanitaire et
puis surtout des enjeux économiques de
la relance dans quelques instants ce
sera l'une des premières thématiques
abordées pierre lux à présent
représentante de la république en marche
dans les yvelines
je rappelle que nadia est la députée
démissionnaire et était dans vos rangs
et qu'aujourd'hui elle est membre du
gouvernement
tout d'abord merci pour l'espace
médiatique que vous nous offrez avec ce
débat effectivement la publicité
l'élection c'est vraiment le premier
enjeu puisque on attend il dans une
abstention très élevé sur une élection
partielle très peu médiatisé sait jamais
une bonne chose d'autant plus que en
élection comme comme toujours c'est
c'est un choix que d'autres citoyens
d'abord un choix politique
voilà quand les toits que je défends
c'est celle d'un député qui c'est gras
dans la majorité présidentielle
ce qui permet en fait le mettre plus
dans lumière la circonscription de
mettre plus en valeur les progrès qui
sont construits et ça peut paraître à
être un député qui portera des
propositions de fond qui défendra des
choses concrètes et non pas quelqu'un
qui travaille une opposition et on l'a
vu malheureusement les oppositions
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
pourquoi mais c'est aussi un choix de
personnes voient la crise on les crée
depuis quatre ans si mon premier
engagement politique
j'ai pas d'autre mandat je sais pas un
professionnel de la politique correcte
baigneurs et je suis très pense qu'il
est important d'avoir un député qui
soient consacrés à ce qui fait qu'ils
aient pas d'autre mandat
on peut pas faire un travail à plein
temps largement à plein temps comme
celui d'un député et en plus avoir à
être conseiller départemental ou
régional sont là aussi des dvd et des
vrai job
voilà on fait de la figuration c'est la
figure à ce trou plutôt bien payé moi je
suis là pour servir pas pour me servir
voilà pourquoi la connexion que je
propose c'est celle d'un député impliqué
à 100%
quatre ans mais en fait le témoignage de
la vie quotidienne d'un jeune citoyen
travailleur pour proposer des avancées
concrètes
il sera capable de contrôler que les
lois votées au parlement répondre
vraiment aux problèmes de la vie
quotidienne
elles sont correctement appliquées je
porte la voix de tous les habitants de
la circonscription et pas uniquement que
s'avérait pas de porte voix juste pour
quelques reins je vous arrête aussi là
le temps de parole sinon va s'envoler un
petit peu gardé du temps ensuite pour
pouvoir échanger sur ce premier tour de
table pour l'instant essayons d'être
peut-être plutôt rapide et kamal ben
marouf la du collectif république
paraison quels sont les enjeux de ce
scrutin selon vous alors j'en vois
quatre tout d'abord l'élection de sept
nouveaux députés en france d'un autre ne
va pas modifier l'équipe de l'assemblée
nationale la république en marche et ses
alliés resteront majoritaires le
gouvernement actuel restera en place
omer en jeu il ira tous - débuté la
majorité ou d'opposition 2éme en jeu
dans la seconde hypothèse laquelle de
toutes les oppositions en compétition
aujourd'hui choisir at on vous demandera
de débuter un double nature tant
nationales par la discussion et vote des
lois que local comme relais entre les
institutions des citoyens tant du haut
vers le bas que du bas vers le haut
troisième enjeu
quels seront l'attitude et le travail du
député élu à l'assemblée nationale
quatrième en jeu quels seront l'attitude
et le travail du député face à ses
concitoyens patrick planque candidats
lutte ouvrière à présent même question
enjeux de ce scrutin selon vous à moi
pour moi le principal enjeu est en
particulier pour les travailleurs c'est
d'affirmer leurs intérêts vitaux
face à la crise économique actuelle il
faut utiliser ce scrutin pour affirmer
que les travailleurs n'ont pas à payer
cette crise c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui
catastrophique et à six cent mille
chômeurs de plus par rapport au mois de
février
sans compter tous les travailleurs qui
sont retrouvés au chômage partiel
aujourd'hui et dont le salaire a été
amputé depuis des mois et des mois on
voit tous les jours des plans de
licenciement
alinéa auchan qui appartiennent à des
grands groupes comme heuliez
on vient d'apprendre la fermeture de
bridgestone avait une c est inadmissible
des plans de licenciements qui ce qui
perdure on va voilà est la seule
proposition aujourd'hui du gouvernement
macron c'est redonner encore des
subventions sans contrepartie aux
capitalistes aux grands au grand
patronat nous si on se présente dans
cette élection c'est vraiment pour faire
entendre le camp des travailleurs pour
dire que de toute façon les élections
c'est pas comme ça que ça va changer
c'est en se mobilisant en se bagarrant
en s'organisant dans les emplois pour
les emplois pour pour protester contre
ces plans une catastrophique pour le
monde du travail
grand comme candidate pour génération
également soutenue par europe ecologie
les verts vous êtes aussi premier
adjoint t'attrape et et enseignante
puisque vous allez donner les
confessions d'un certain moi je crois
que c'est l'occasion unique la d'envoyer
une députée de gauche écologistes à
l'assemblée ça va pas bousculer les
rapports de force mais ça sera une voie
supplémentaire pour dénoncer les
politiques qui sont menées actuellement
pour dénoncer la déconnexion qu'il y a
de la part du gouvernement sur beaucoup
de sujets qui n'est pas du tout en phase
ce qui se passe sur le terrain
et puis c'est aussi l'occasion de
t'envoyer assembler une députée qui
connaît bien le territoire et qui se
battra pour défendre les dossiers les
dossiers qui sont des enjeux majeurs sur
ce territoire et nouveau terminons ce
premier tour de table avec thibaut
langlois vous est le suppléant sur cette
candidature de valérie froberger pour
l'alliance du parti communiste et de la
france insoumise quels sont les enjeux
pour vous cette élection c'est d'abord
un symbole dans une circonscription il
salue niçoise emmanuel macron il s'agit
de porter une voix celle du monde du
travail celle des premiers corps d'aidé
soignant ses dossiers d'une écologie
populaire et c'est pourquoi le nom
particulier c est france un sionisme
nous avons décidé de soutenir la
candidature de valimo berger qui est
attrayante à l'hôpital de garches et
qu'israël est continu des combats car
agir concrètement agir face aux élites
monaco se prépare en ce moment un
cependant cette rentrée les
licenciements massifs encore autour de
la réforme des retraites
on l'a vu samedi dernier on va le voir
encore demain avec la grande
manifestation interprofessionnelle il ya
dans la population le souhaite notre
optique et il ya une chance évidente
entre ses prestations dans la rue et
c'est et ses propositions que nous
souhaitons porter dans les institutions
et pour cela il n'y a qu'un seul
de poids celui de valérie berger que je
prie d'excuser cas est actuellement en
train de préparer la manifestation de ce
premier tour de table je précise que
philippe benassaya le maire les
républicains de bois d'arcy également
engagé dans cette campagne devrait nous
rejoindre en cours d'émission et puis si
la connexion le permet cette fois ci
laurent creton qui a aussi accepté de
participer qui représente le père
devrait pouvoir nous rejoindre nous
allons aborder si le temps nous permet
trois thématiques l'économie
l'environnement et la sécurité
rappelons aussi pour ceux qui nous
suivent celles et ceux qui nous suivent
que les députés participent au travail
législatif au travail de contrôle du
gouvernement et propose des lois les
votes
interroge les ministres également ne
sont pas uniquement là pour représenter
leur circonscription il s'exprime aussi
au nom du peuple ce qui fait que les
thématiques sont plutôt au national que
nous allons aborder et justement parlons
du plan de relance initié par le
gouvernement le pays comme le reste du
monde a été fortement impactée pensez
vous les uns les autres que lé mesures
vont dans le bon sens les auriez vous
voté aussi si vous étiez déjà à
l'assemblée on va commencer avec vous
olivier galland et puisque vous avez
parlé seulement pendant une vingtaine de
secondes c'est vous qui avaient le plus
de retard jusqu'à présent on vous écoute
que pensez vous des mesures qui ont été
annoncées du plan de relance globalement
sur l'économie aujourd'hui ce plan de
relance pour moi il m'a l'air compliqué
il m'a l'air un peu confus il va un
petit peu dans tous les sens on scelle
par si on sème par l'ars va donner tant
de milliards pour la relance à condition
qu'ils aient des aspects écologiques
tant milliards déjà affecté le
financement de ce plan
on n'a pas trop compris c'est un autre
aspect nombre à la france emprunte 100
milliards les denrées vers ce que 40
voilà ça me paraît très complexe
aujourd'hui la situation s'est laissé la
suivante
les pme ont des difficultés parce que
pendant des mois elles ont raison dû
payer leurs charges voulu pays alors
locaux leur leur leur matériel leurs
emprunts et pendant ce temps là vendée
rien donc nous notre proposition elle
est très simple un c'est de libérer les
pme qui créent donc en france le
principal facteur de création libérer
les pme de ce boulet qu'elles ont et de
leur faire une suppression global de
charges sur le deuxième trimestre de
l'année 2020 voilà nous c'est vraiment
l'orientation qu'on estime indispensable
pour relancer l'économie en france et la
relancer durablement en ma présence je
vous passe la parole même chose vous
vous avez une trentaine de secondes de
temps de parole les autres candidats je
le précise sont un peu plus d'une minute
pour pierre lucet et c'est au tour des
deux minutes de temps de parole c'est
vous qui avez le plus d' avance sandrine
grande sur ce plan de relance genre
donne quelques lignes il ya 100
milliards d'euros baptisé le france
relance c'est financé à 40% par l'union
européenne également il ya plusieurs
volets plusieurs promesses qui ont été
faites aux entreprises de leur venir en
aide
si vous étiez en poste est ce que vous
auriez voter tout simplement le plan de
relance et les différentes mesures vous
les auriez soutenu clairement l'ont tout
simplement parce que on vit une crise
sanitaire et une crise sociale et
économique sans précédent et les
réponses ne sont pas à la hauteur en
fait ce sont des vieilles méthodes les
vieilles méthodes libérales qui sont
utilisés moi je pense a été relayé
largement sur les réseaux sociaux mais
où sont les mesures pour les plus
fragiles ceux qui la remet en pris plein
la tête depuis le mois de mars qui ont
décroché on voit dans nos villes en
grande difficulté et mesure pour ces
gens là elles sont donc il ya clairement
un volet entier qui manque et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment vous met le paquet
sur tout ce qui va être innovation
économique et sociale on a sur le
territoire il
une entreprise qui s'appelle en vie
exemplaire sur le plan de la vente
d'électroménager où on met en place un
système on recycle fait de l'insertion
moi je pense que c'est vraiment ce
modèle-là qu'il faut développer l'emploi
demain pierre du jeu vous passez tout de
même la parole parce que vous êtes le
représentant aussi de la majorité si
vous êtes élu vous siégeraient au sein
de la majorité quand vous entendez que
les plans de relance
donc par exemple un pan entier nous dit
sandrine grand gang vous partagez non je
partagerai je pense qu'il faut le lire
en entier pour pour comprendre de ses
presque assez rapide en plus c'est à
dire on voit bien qu'il ya tout un pan
justement qui qui s'adresse à notamment
l'insertion dans l'emploi les plus
fragiles qui il ya près de cent mille
formations qui vont être ouvertes pour
les jeunes sont peu qualifiés il ya
trois semaines parcours d'insertion
professionnelle qui vont être moins de
créer effectivement pas uniquement sur
l'économie capitaliste puisque on va
avoir par exemple dans le plan de
relance de l'investissement sur les
centres de tri comme dire qu'ils et
elles sont de tri du relais qui traite
les vêtements déposés les bornes
ils ont besoin de s'étendre et on aime
développer leur activité ils ont après
70 personnes en insertion veulent
doubler ce chiffre
donc c'est aussi tout ça le plan de
relance il faut pas l'oublier mais on a
préservé le le pouvoir de créer avec
l'activité partielle pendant le choc le
chômage partiel pendant le confinement
et pendant l'été maintenant il faut
relancer la machine
ces gars là ont parlé des pme
effectivement il faut les aider c'est
pour ça que l'état va garantir notamment
un fonds d'investissement en fonds
propres qui permettent en fait d'avoir
de l'argent qui ne soient pas des dettes
pour les pme et des tpe
laurent brun pour le rassemblement
national votre point de vue sur cette
question du plan de relance et des aides
qui ont été attribués écoutez difficile
de se faire un point d'un point de vue
très très clair parce qu'effectivement
ce plan est passé flou c'est un sujet
très sérieux qui engage les finances de
l'état et qui doit répondre à des
problématiques extrêmement grave en
termes socio économique
on a déjà et on va avoir une crise
économique qui va qui va arriver qui va
s'ajouter à la crise à la crise
sanitaire
et c'est vrai que ce plan moi j'ai
plusieurs plusieurs remarques dont une
dans une qui m'interpelle énormément
dont première remarque ce plan
visiblement le gouvernement n'y croit
pas lui-même puisqu'en fait il table sur
une création de 160 mille emplois alors
qu'on a déjà
on sait déjà qu'il va y avoir huit cent
mille emplois de détruits donc soit le
plan est insuffisant soit il est mal
orienté la deuxième remarque c'est qu'il
arrive trop tard
il arrive trop tard par rapport à
d'autres pays qui l'ont déjà mines qui
ont déjà mis en place des plans qui ont
déjà des entreprises qui ont fait
faillite il ya déjà beaucoup d'emplois
qui ont été ont été détruits donc pour
moi il arrive trop tard sur le sujet de
la relocalisation qui est vraiment un
sujet est centrale dans nos
problématiques actuelles on l'a vu
notamment au moins de la crise de la
dollée pandémie du pic de l'épidémie où
on n'avait pas de masque pas de test où
il nous manquait à peu près à peu près
tout et c'est vrai que la relocalisation
c'est vraiment le coeur du problème
cela pourrait répondre avec un grand
plan de relocalisation vous pourrez
répondre aux différentes problématiques
socio économiques sanitaires et même
environnementale sauf que dans le plan
de relance on a un milliard simplement 1
milliards sur les 100 milliards mais le
point le plus important est le j'attire
l'attention des électeurs et de
l'ensemble de l'ensemble des débatteurs
de ce soir c'est le financement contre
plan n'est pas financée sur les 100
milliards du plan d' emmanuel macron il
y à 40 milliards qui provient de l'union
européenne et 60 milliards qui provient
d'un emprunt que l'état va faire alors
l'état on est déjà à 100 % du pib en
termes de dette
et là on passe d'un seul ou à 120% donc
c'est déjà une dérive
assez assez impressionnante mais surtout
la problématique c'est sur les 40
milliards qui proviennent de l'union
européenne qui proviennent en fait de la
subvention de 390 milliards qui est
comprise dans les 750 milliards du plan
de relance européen
ces 40 milliards normalement et je vais
vraiment aller allez-y essayer d'être
d'être confiée à laurent maurage sur le
temps de parole vous êtes à plus de 4
minutes et vous prenez beaucoup d'avancé
je peux reprendre du temps sur ce sujet
plutôt que sur un autre parce que c'est
vraiment essentiel
ces 40 milliards ne sont qui proviennent
de l'union européenne normalement
doivent être financés sur fonds sur sur
des ressources propres de l'union
européenne les ressources propres ce
sont des impôts or l'union européenne ne
pourra pas créer un impôt parce qu'il
faut l'unanimité des états membres ce
qui veut dire que va financer les 40
milliards et des 390 milliards même pour
l'ensemble des états membres ce sont les
coups les contributions de chaque état
membre sauf que avec le breakbeat et les
rabais des pays fruits
au haut niveau européen la contribution
de la france est passé à 15 % 15 % de
390 milliards ces 60 milliards ça veut
dire qu'en fait l'europe nous donne 40
milliards mais on va lui redonner 60
milliards en fait c'est une supercherie
ce plan on perd plus d'argent que l'on
va en gagner et je vous interromps la
voilà vous êtes après près de cinq
minutes vous aurez forcément moins de
temps pour vous exprimer sur les autres
thématiques thibault langlois qu'il
fallait froberger candidat pcf et les
filles votre regard également sur le
plan de relance les mesures si vous êtes
élu comment vous allez agir aussi sur
ces questions-là bien ce plan de relance
comme où c'est en quelque sorte un acte
manqué beaucoup d'argent il n'y aurait
pas le serbe manquera deux sens le temps
se calme
voyez par exemple les investissements
qui ont été faits en faveur du secteur
automobile il me semble que mon plan
d'urgence au secteur s'élève à près de
1000 r de vaud le moment mais surtout
aux biens a bien pour bono qui s'annonce
entre ses effectifs de recherche et
développement alors même que les défis
en termes de choix du lieu des 20
milliards d'euros en baisse d'impôts
indiscriminée sur les entreprises sans
contrepartie
si en plus présent par un point fort de
manquer gagner ou les paris dont les
services publics
il faut faire les choses dans l'ordre
empêchant vocation alors but social et
environnemental
il faut pêcher ses ailes afin de
permettre la création d'emplois durables
et les valorisant en à travers notamment
la reconversion des industries qui sont
même assez confronté au défi lu tion du
changement climatique et on va
localisant les industries de services
bien sûr pour cela s'appuyer sur les
travailleurs qui sont les plus à même de
jambes on sait le changement du statut
de profession à travers de nouveaux
droits
où la participation au sein à une
annonce de l'entreprise aussi je pense
reconstituer secteur public fort qui
sera capable de donner une impulsion
concrètes dans des secteurs stratégiques
et que par exemple la banque et énergie
ou encore le médicament la création d'un
impôt publie des médicaments par exemple
permettre de prévenir et des nuits qui
ont goûté on sait et on écrit syndicales
vous en anglais en ont besoin patrick
lange où je vous pose à propos à présent
la même question avec aussi ceux parmi
ce plan de relance il ya aussi tout de
même une volonté soutenir l'emploi des
plus vénérables il ya une enveloppe de 7
7 milliards qui sera dédiée à un plan
jeunes par exemple est ce que ce sont
des mesures qui vont dans le bon sens
peut-être qu'il ya des choses à garder
de votre point de vue dans ce plan de
relance
à mon avis il ya rien à garder c'est un
cadeau comme depuis très longtemps aux
grandes entreprises de ce pays que ce
gouvernement ou ceux où le précédent ou
celui même d'avant de toute façon ils
n'ont qu elle ça comme proposition il
faut aider les entreprises aider les
entreprises qui vont continuer à
licencier
juste quand même pour replacer un peu
dans le contexte 100 milliards on aurait
la possibilité et si l'état avait
réellement la volonté de créer des
emplois dans les collectivités il y
aurait pu y avoir aussi cette
possibilité là 100 milliards c'est 2,7
millions d'emplois à 1800 euros nets
cotisations incluse pour un an
oui réellement aujourd'hui dans les
transports dans les écoles dans les
hôpitaux il aurait fallu embaucher est
juste un petit mot quand même parce
qu'on a parlé un moment du chômage
partiel
aujourd'hui il ya une vraie supercherie
parce que qui c'est qui paye qui c'est
qui paye le chômage partiel c'est la
collectivité en partie alors on y en ai
dit que c'est pour essayer de sauver les
emplois
regardez-le usine de peugeot poissy
peugeot poissy ou poissy peugeot ils
sont de riches à milliards
ils sont en pleine forme santé n'empêche
que il continue à chaponnay leur usine
cinq heures par jour à fond et deux
heures tous les jours tous les salariés
de l'usiné sont au chômage partiel c'est
ça qui est inadmissible aujourd'hui et
ce plan de relance il va dans ce sens là
il va dans le sens de favoriser les
entreprises qui vont continuer à
licencier à faire des plans de
licenciements et à fermer des emplois
kamel ben marouf la présente vous a pas
encore entendu vous représentez le
collectif je le disais république par
raison également candidat sur cette 11e
circonscription avec et quel programme
sur le plan politique et économique
justement et qu'elle regarde sur ce qui
est menée jusqu'à présent vous aussi
alors donc là il s'agit bien de gras du
volet économique du plan de relance tout
à fait les 100 milliards d'euros qui ont
été débloqués le feu le plan france
relance financé à 40% par l'union
européenne alors juste je suis allée de
consulter sur le site web du
gouvernement et j'ai voulu voir ça de
loin
toujours du côté des principes parce que
je pense que c'est là que ça se joue
il ya deux citations qui m'ont
interpellé la première le plan de
relance permet de libérer les énergies
de la nation pour renouer avec la
croissance
voilà on continue de s'enfoncer dans le
dogme dans le dogme de la croissance
selon lequel et travaillant dans
d'autres choix que de travailler plus
pour gagner plus selon une formule bien
connue et historiquement c'est cette
religion dû produire toujours plus qui
nous a conduits à la ville écologique
en deuxième partie 2 de seconde citation
déploiement de l'activité partielle de
longue durée assorti d'un plan de
formation
l'air de rien il s'agit de rendre la
définitif ce qui s'est mis en place
durant le confinement et cela ne streaks
mithra certainement pas à l'économie je
pense par exemple à l'éducation
nationale et à la sécurité sociale dont
je suis convaincu que l'effondrement il
devenait inévitable
au delà je suis convaincu une inévitable
effondrement nous institution à court
terme au profit du seul profit du grand
marché mondial pour lequel tous négocié
s'achète et se vend jusqu'à nos
personnels aux âmes
c'est bien pour ça que vous comprendrez
que je crois pas un instant à ce plan de
relance en tout cas dans son volet
économique nous parlons technologique
juste après nous passons la deuxième
thématique de ce débat il est question
d'environnement à présent il en est
largement question dans le plan de
relance forcément nous allons entrer un
peu plus en détails il faut savoir qu'il
ya 30 milliards dédiés à la transition
écologique ou encore 11 milliards pour
les transports 1 9 milliard pour
l'industrie l'énergie est ce que là
aussi toutes les mesures vont dans le
bon sens c'est ce que si vous êtes élu
les uns les autres
si l'un d'entre vous et donc sera élu
quelle mesure soutien soutiendra-t-il
soutiendra-t-elle
je vais vous passez la parole pierre
luce tout d'abord en précisant que sur
cette suite de débats philippe benassaya
nous a rejoint mer et l'air de bois
d'arcy bonsoir à vous merci j'avais
précisé que vous aviez une obligation
aux débuts de démission par contre
thibault langlois représentants de
valérie froberger à lui une quitté en
cours de débat en raison des problèmes
techniques je rappelle que onze
candidats se présentent sur ce scrutin
nous avons tout fait pour essayer de
tous les avoir simultanément dans les
conditions que vous connaissez sur le
plan sanitaire également d'où la vision
pierre luce je vous passe la parole
candidats lrm et revenons sur cette
question de l'environnement et sur le
bon sens ou non de ces mesures
appliquées effectivement le travail
parlementaire reste à faire sur sur ce
plan de relance l'analyse du le travail
autour du projet de loi de finances va
débuter à partir d'octobre et donc la
partie en dehors de mental en fait elle
s'intègre vraiment au reste du plan elle
est très concret très pragmatique on
n'est pas du tout dans dans l'écologie
sanctions dans les grandes idées à
lasséran les projets du quotidien des
projets palpable qui devront être lancés
d'ici à deux ans par exemple ça va être
subventionné une ressourcerie afin
qu'elles puissent augmenter ses
capacités à réutiliser du matériel
d'occasion ça peut être entre elysée
remplacer une vieille chaudière à
charbon par une centrale biomasse un peu
plus un peu plus verte et économe
toutes ces mesures comme l'elysée c'est
un ensemble en fait ça permet de mettre
en place un modèle industriel et
agricole plus vertueux de par exemple de
décarbonés le l'industrie c'est ce que
le site est par exemple avec la des
chaudières
c'est vraiment un ensemble de petits
progrès pas forcément des projets à
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
mais qui partout dans toutes les
industries dans tout l'est et les
secteurs culturels et les exploitations
on a besoin d'un petit coup de pouce
pour passer le cap de cette transition
c'est la même chose pour l'isolation
thermique des bâtiments on a partout en
france des bâtiments publics des
bâtiments privés que sur les maisons de
particuliers ou des immeubles de
bailleurs sociaux qui ont besoin d'être
rénovées énergétiquement et on met sur
la table 7 milliards d'euros pour
subventionner
ce ces travaux là qui vont pas être à la
fois de faire des économies importantes
qu'il ya des ménages qui parfois
dépenses 1000 euros par mois de
chauffage pour être mal chauffés et
c'est en plus souvent les personnes qui
sont déjà le plus en difficulté ceci est
connu pour l'état pour tous ces
bâtiments publics et en plus ça va créer
de l'emploi
ça va créer une dynamique vertueuse pour
le notamment le secteur du bâtiment
premier fait que notre vision de
l'écologie la protection de
l'environnement le cadre de vie sont pas
des sujets élitiste c'est pas les sujets
de beaux gosses et du quotidien qu'on
veut vivre un logement mal isolé mal
aéré dans un quartier où vous voulez à
une mauvaise qualité vous développer
davantage de prêts aux escalators et est
donc vous êtes plus sensibles à tout ça
bien manger mieux se déplacer c'est pas
un problème qu'elle les avait au risque
c'est un problème pour tout le monde et
donc moi je suis pas celui qui lira aux
habitants de trac ou de la verrière que
l'écologie veut c'est pas une priorité
pour leurs enfants qui met elle pas
aussi de vivre dans un air pur de manger
une nourriture saine d'avoir une eau non
polluée ou un logement confortable
divers non nous on s'adresse à travers
nos mesures écologiques à tout le monde
et on passe comporte ton est concerné
sandrine grand-combe votre regard aussi
sur son plan de relance et puis plus
concrètement est-ce que vous si vous
êtes élu ça fait partie de la priorité
aujourd'hui ces questions
environnementales ou qui était lui
attrape aussi je leur apporte comme sur
le sujet précédent
les propositions sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux on l'a vu on voit avec ce
qu'on vit sur le plan climatique
l'urgence climatique elle est là sur la
question donc on l'a vu aussi dans
l'actualité de la 5g on a des débats de
fond de société qu'il faut mener
et la réponse que l'on a après nous
avoir baladé sur la convention citoyenne
sur l'environnement où il y avait plein
de propositions
au final décompose les éléments du débat
c'est circulez ya rien à voir
parce qu'on voit bien que c'est pas une
priorité en fait des politiques qui sont
menées actuellement ce soit sur le
bien-être animal dans les abattoirs
que ce soit sur les lobby de la chasse
qui ont porte ouverte au gouvernement
que ce soit sur la question des
pesticides on recule en fait par rapport
aux décisions qui avaient été prises
y'a pas un sujet où on n'a pas des
reculs ou des décisions qui sont des
décisions qui vont
entre le la problématique
environnementale donc c'est bien les
beaux discours mais après il ya les
actes et les actes pour l'instant ça
suis pas donc il faut clairement que ces
questions là le soin au coeur de nos
politiques et qu'il y ait des voix à
l'assemblée nationale et non pas des
gens qui vont dire on accompagne et oui
le gouvernement a raison mais qui disent
clairement là il ya des problématiques
qui ne sont pas traités qu'il faut
urgemment traités et quelles priorités
pour vous si vous êtes élu vous pourriez
faire une proposition de loi allant dans
ce sens par exemple sur quels domaines
précis vous basant sur votre votre
commune par exemple moi qui me tiennent
à coeur ça a été évoqué sur la question
de de comment on a une énergie propre
toute la question de la rénovation mais
la peur de vivre qui se sont lancés dans
la géothermie
je pense qu'on peut très bien avoir des
plans par ville où on développe la
géothermie on peut avoir un plan énergie
propre dans chaque ville s'appelle une
proposition de loi comme il ya des
obligations en termes de logements
sociaux
vous pouvez très bien développé une voix
à l'angle de dans ce genre de nouveaux
domaines qui sont qui sont essentiels
philippe benassaya je vous passe la
parole à à présent mais les républicains
sur bois d'arcy candidat dans ce scrutin
également soutien de la droite sur le
sur le scrutin pour vous la question de
l'environnement de l'écologie priorité
des priorités si vous êtes élue députée
un priorité mais je vois surtout qu'il
faudrait peut-être un jour sortir de la
polémique sur l'écologie dont ne veut
pas avoir des visions d'écologie mais
une vision d'environnement et qui
devraient partager de partout long de la
droite à gauche en passant par le centre
je trouve qu'en france ces questions
sont encore trop idéologique il faudrait
tout d'abord à mon avis sortir déjà d'un
logiciel idéologique pour parler
l'environnement concret il faut être lié
à des bonnes 6 et un peu partout très
honnêtement je suis un élu local jeu
j'ai appliqué une politique
d'environnement cadre de vie dans ma
dans ma ville qui a plutôt bien marché
avec plusieurs labels et récompenses
avec eux des vraies problématiques des
vraies politiques
matière de développement durable
d'innovation de d'économie de protection
de l'environnement pour essayer d'allier
un peu tout ça je pense qu'il faut
sortir mon avis de cette écologique et
saine un peu que l'on voit aujourd'hui
en france cette espèce d'écologie à peu
caricatural punitive et est passé à une
écologie pu partager plus positive +
plus libre et ça c'est avant de
commencer à voir les micros sujet à
droite et à gauche il faudrait peut-être
déjà sortir un petit peu de ce logiciel
l'a essayé d'avoir une écologie partagé
par tous et une surtout une écologie qui
soient également prises en compte et
piloté par les élus locaux je pense que
c'est important aussi de faire remonter
les bonnes pratiques du terrain et ne
pas attendre que le coq dfid pour le bas
voilà olivier galland debout la france
votre vision de l'écologie de
l'environnement ou si tu debout la
france dans cette question là alors si
vous avez un petit peu entendu tout le
monde quand on parle écologie
environnement chacun a son avis est en
fait j'ai l'impression qu'on parle pas
tous des mêmes choses se focalise sur
sur certains aspects donc pour certains
l'écologie c'est le réchauffement
climatique diminution du carbone énergie
j'en ai même entendu qu'il par l'aide
sociale ici de décroissance eux
pour moi c'est surtout le cadre de vie
quand on parle d'environnement ce qui
nous intéresse au quotidien c'est c'est
le cadre du loria des choses qui ont été
faites au cours des dernières années qui
ont bien marché
tu prends l'exemple du tri sélectif et
le tri sélectif qu'est-ce qui sait
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a mis en
place des filières en france et on a
fait l'éducation mois dans les écoles de
saint-cyr l'école mes enfants vont à des
déchetteries vont à des centres de tri
ils ont des cours sur le tri sélectif
été globalement je dirais que ça se
passe très bien c'est un projet mené de
a à z
au niveau de l'état et des collectivités
et je pense que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire
à côté de ça il ya des choses qu'il ne
faut surtout pas faire
on a vu là les taxes sur l'essence qui
avec ont été le début d'un gilet jaune
voilà mettre des taxes mettre des taxes
mettre des taxes à c'est ce qui se passe
france depuis depuis des années ça ne
marche pas on prend les français pour
des idiots 10 idiot en leur disant que
si on augmente les taxes on respire
mieux
c'est faux après pour moi l'écologie et
commence devant sa porte
devant sa porte c'est bien de dire aux
gens vous allez vous chauffez mieux et
moins cher mais si devant chez soi c'est
jonchées d'ordures
ça ne mène à rien donc il ya quand même
quelque chose à faire dans nos villes
c'est d'apprendre aux gens qu'on ne
jette pas les papiers par par la fenêtre
de sa voiture qu'on ne connaît pas ses
papiers par terre quand les poubelles
sont pleines et une éducation à faire là
et je pense que c'est vraiment le niveau
zéro de l'environnement après moi si
j'étais à l'assemblée il ya deux choses
que je ferais chez de gaulle la france
on a une déléguée à la dignité animale
qui est vice présidente
les animaux pour nous c'est vraiment un
sujet très important et qui m'interpelle
personnellement cette année comme tous
les ans il ya eu des abandons il ya cent
mille animaux qui sont abandonnés tous
les ans il ya la spa qui a fait une
campagne spéciale
c'est inadmissible cueillette ou ces
abandons d'animaux et il faut légiférer
dans ce sens
ça c'est le premier bois le deuxième
point je sais pas si vous avez vu la
californie cet été ils sont ni aux
panneaux solaires aux éoliennes et
ensuite ils ont arrêté le nucléaire et
finalement ils se sont retrouvés avec un
black out depuis depuis des années chez
de la france
on propose de relancer la recherche sur
les seuls fonds dieu qui est nouvelle
filière nucléaire et le gouvernement
la république en marche quand on quand
on a posé des questions aux députés mais
quand les députés ont posé des questions
aux milices a toujours été la même chose
le nucléaire on n'en veut pas de toute
façon à faire des énergies vertes on en
a pas besoin
voilà donc il faut relancer la recherche
il faut trouver des solutions il faut
quitter le dogmatisme de l'antinucléaire
vous voyez pendant que les dégâts l'on
parlait il ya plusieurs points sur
lesquels vous sembliez d'accord aussi
cette vision de l'écologie vous convient
non faussée
je n'ai pas du tout n'est pas du tout
prévu de dire la même chose mais je
reconnais une position cohérente même si
c'est totalement autre chose que j'ai
envie de dire vers l'asie vous et à vous
exprimer sur la question voilà ça tombe
bien alors vision d'écologie mais il
s'agit aussi de s'exprimer sur les
mesures du plan de relance si j'ai bien
compris tout à fait qu'elles vivent au
plan de relance concernant la question
dans lequel l'écologie de
l'environnement vous alors comme tout à
l'heure
là cette fois ci c'est une citation qui
m'a interpellé luigi faire bref je vous
dis pas ce que ça vaut son pesant de
cacahuètes rénovation thermique des
bâtiments
l'aide à la décarbonation de l'industrie
je ne connaissais pas ce terme les je
devine ce que recèle le bonus écologique
la prime à la conversion pour l'achat
d'un véhicule propre ou encore la
transformation du secteur agricole mais
également la recherche et l'innovation
pour le développement de technologies
vertes
alors ça c'est discours classique de ce
que l'on appelle depuis un petit bout de
temps le capitalisme vert dernières
évolutions du grand marché mondial pour
lequel désormais la nature elle-même
devient biens de consommation et c'est
là le véritable péril contre notre
espèce l'humanité mais houda contre la
vie elle-même en terme d'écologie
la france est une des rares nations
ayant donné une valeur constitutionnelle
à la défense de la nature
je voudrais vous le rappeler c'est la
charte de l'environnement de 2004 voulue
par le président jacques chirac dans la
droite ligne de sa célèbre citation
notre maison brûle et nous regardons
ailleurs bien de dire pourquoi ne
reprendront pas ce socle
sur lequel je pense qu'il ya eu un
énorme consensus qui à l'époque pour
définir la politique écologique de la
france et peut-être même au-delà inspiré
bien au delà mon sentiment
sinon non je vois là je pense qu'en
réalité il ne s'agit que l'on retrouve
cette idéologie marchande
derrière la défense de la nature c'est
mon sentiment et je serais pas surpris
de dire que je dois vous dire que je
m'oppose à cela patrick lang cas présent
candidats lutte ouvrière
oui bah il ya pas mal de choses qui ont
été dites avec lesquels je ne suis pas
d'accord ont bien évidemment ce plan de
relance il va il va en matière
d'écologie
il va de toute façon dans le même sens
c'est à dire qu'il va favoriser les
grandes entreprises les grandes
entreprises capitalistes le scandale de
lafarge qui verse qui déversent des
déchets dans la seine
c'est inadmissible et bien évidemment si
les travailleurs étaient au pouvoir
bien évidemment il y aurait des choses à
contrôler et à ce niveau là en ce qui
concerne les mesures qu'ils ont annoncés
on parle énormément du fret ferroviaire
alors je suis bien placé je suis
cheminot je connais la situation
le fret ferroviaire depuis des années et
des années on a fermé on a licencié les
chiffres c'est 120 mille cent vingt
mille salariés dans le fret ferroviaire
en 2000 il y en a plus de 4000
aujourd'hui et on vient nous expliquer
que assas rsa qu'il faudrait mettre en
avant non c'est de la rigolade
ils n'ont pas envie de faire ça ils
n'ont pas du tout envie de faire ça ils
vont continuer à favoriser des
entreprises à favoriser les grands
groupes industriels et on essaye de
tirer on essaye de de présenter la
personne leleu
le locataire l'habitant lambda comme
responsable est bon et bien évidemment
c'est pas ça la situation malgré tout
j'aurais quand même envie de dire de
faire une petite remarque je ne suis pas
intervenu par rapport à 1 par rapport à
l'intervention de monsieur luce les gens
les gens des classes moyennes les
ouvriers ils dépensent pas 1000 euros en
chopant en chauffage ils n'ont pas une
passe à en salaire donc ils ne dépensent
pas 1000 euros en chauffage ce n'est pas
possible quand on connaît la situation
par exemple aller des yvelines a trap ou
tout l'hiver il n'y a pas eu de
chauffage alors que les ans il est le
bailleur avait les subventions bah oui
on se rend bien compte que la situation
ça va pas se régler comme ça ça va se
régler par la mobilisation des
travailleurs et des salariés et des
idées et des locataires dans l'est dans
les cités si vous souhaitez répondre
pierre l'ush brièvement comme vous avez
été interpellé
est ce parce qu'ensuite la parole alors
en moins pour l'un simplement nationale
rapidement j'ai avec eux malheureusement
s'il ya des ménages modestes qui
d'extrêmes difficultés pour chauffer
quand ça vous coûte 5 à 6000 euros pour
faire le plein d'une citerne de fioul
si vous ramenez ça au nombre de mois
d'hiver on est sur cet ordre de grandeur
c'est évidemment hors de prix beaucoup
ne peuvent pas le faire et donc du coup
ne se chauffent pas tout simplement
donc après je ne me croyais pas saouler
malheureusement cette situation
sa parole donc à laurent morin
responsable du rassemblement national
dans les yvelines est également candidat
sur cette 11e circonscription votre
sentiment sur cette question d'écologie
de l'environnement vous aurez à peu près
une minute si vous voulez garder du
temps pour aborder le dernier thème la
sécurité
voilà je le précise je suis toujours un
peu gêné avec ce sujet environnemental
non pas qu'ils n'apparaissent pas il
m'intéresse
non pas qu'il ne s'agisse pas uniquement
en jeu c'est véritablement un enjeu mais
la manière dont il est généralement
abordés et bien souvent étrange parce
que on occulte
on occulte les principales raisons et on
prend à la place des mesures certains
certains l'ont dit des mesures
cosmétiques tantôt punitif tantôt
farfelues farfelu on a eu des exemples
notamment à bordeaux dernièrement à lyon
rennais également et en fait on occulte
les deux principaux phénomènes qui
explique la qui pourrait expliquer la la
dégradation de l'environnement et les
deux phénomènes c'est tout d'abord
l'augmentation de la population mondiale
ça on n'en parle jamais et l'autre
phénomène c'est le concept de
consommation dans notre existence
effective donc pas ces deux sujets de
manière efficace alors toutes les autres
mesures qu'on pourrait prendre ce que
l'on des voeux pieux seront qu'une
chimère alors au delà de ça ça n'empêche
pas compris éventuellement proposer un
certain nombre de mesures est en tout
cas au rassemblement national nous
proposons deux mesures qui pour le coup
serait efficace d'un point de vue
environnemental s'est d'abord refusé
décrété de libre échange qui sont une
aberration pour les consommateurs pour
les travailleurs et pour la planète et
enfin défendre le localisme par rappo
par opposition au mondialisme le
localisme c'est donc mettre en place des
circuits courts relocaliser nos
entreprises en france pour éviter
effectivement qu'on a acheté des
produits à l'autre bout du monde et
qu'on fasse on fasse venir par
containers entiers des millions de
produits tout en polluant bien entendu
pas la planète par par le cube consommé
par les parlers porte containers donc
voilà ça fait deux deux propositions là
à mon avis serait beaucoup plus efficace
que par exemple annulé le sapin de noël
à bord et je vous arrête je vous arrête
là pour le temps de parole je vous le
précise puisque vous ne voyez pas
s'afficher les téléspectateurs oui mais
vous non
depuis vos écrans d'ordinateur vous êtes
entre 5 6 minutes à peu près chacun le
roman un peu plus d'avancé autour de 17
minutes sandrine grand gang
vous avez le plus de retard hormis
philippe benassaya mais qui nous a
rejoints en cours de route forcément
sandrine grand quand vous êtes à peu
près à trois minutes et c'est avec vous
que je vais commencer sur la dernière
thématique qui sera la question de la
sécurité pour clarifier le débat à venir
il y a eu un mot qui est revenu ces
derniers jours notamment dans la bouche
du ministre de l'intérieur gérard
darmanin c'est en sauvagement est ce que
c'est un mot déjà qui vous convient et
puis ensuite par rapport aux priorités
qui ont été fixés là aussi par le
gouvernement parce que le rôle d'un
député c'est de regarder ce que les
mesures qui sont qui sont proposés de
les voter voire d'en proposer
parmi les différentes mesures priorités
du gouvernement sur les questions de
sécurité
il ya la lutte contre les stupéfiants la
lutte contre le harcèlement drulhe
également la lutte contre le séparatisme
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on était et
qu'on était lancée et beaucoup de
dossiers qui ont été abordés sens
rennes-caen vous quel serait quel est
selon vous la priorité à avoir et puis
beaucoup d'entre vous et pas uniquement
vous vous êtes des élus locaux en tout
cas vous habitez tous dans la
circonscription certains sont des élus
déjà des maires des maires adjoints
comment vous êtes confrontés comment
vous pouvez agir aujourd'hui face à tous
ces problèmes
sandrine grande je crois pas qu'on a mis
tous deux dans la circonscription que
c'est pas grave
en mission à l'élection nationale mais
la réalité de cette circonscription les
quelques-uns effectivement à la
connaître là en fait la question de la
sécurité elle est indissociable pour moi
de la question des services publics
on est dans là encore des logiques
libérales où on a cassé les services
publics ça n'a pas commencé avec mâcon
mais bien avant
concernant les forces de police il faut
remonter vers nicolas sarkozy pour la
casse dans la dans la police et on en
voit aujourd'hui les résultats
vous savez que sur la circonscription de
trappes elancourt on est sur 170 mille
habitants la nuit il ya trois équipages
donc les gens qui appellent qui font le
17 pour parce qu'ils ont des problèmes
plus ou moins graves à régler avec la
besoin d'un soutien de la police ils
n'ont pas de réponse on les renvoie dans
les vers les mairies en étant appelé le
maire ça c'est pas acceptable
on est sur un champ qui est régalien la
police c'est du domaine des politiques
nationales et on est clairement en
sous-effectif sur des circonscriptions
comme la diam
ça ne peut pas
un peu pas fonctionné et c'est vrai pour
tous les services publics on l'a vécu
avec la poste où on a failli de nouveau
avoir une fermeture sur trappe de du de
reproches du bureau de poste principal
donc quelles que soient les domaines
dont on pourrait parler de la santé on
est tout le temps leur a pleuré quand il
ya des problèmes on l'a vu au moment de
la crise ducobu où on applaudissait tous
les personnels de santé mais quand il
faut concrètement développer les
services publics qui a plus personne
et donc la problématique de la sécurité
qui est absolument essentiel pour le
bien-être de nos concitoyens qui n'en
peuvent plus des incivilités
c'est clairement de redonner de pouvoir
en termes de nombre d'effectifs
donc il faut absolument qu'il y ait
beaucoup plus de présence humaine sur
sur nos territoires
et puis ne pas se lancer dans des sujets
qui sont pas exclues jet qui intéresse
les français la question pour moi de
séparatisme la question de la manière
dont on aborde la lutte contre les
stupéfiants on n'est que dans la com et
là comme ça suffit il faut aujourd'hui
des mesures qui soient clairement celles
qui permettent d'améliorer la vie de nos
chaussures là on en est très loin
est-ce qu'il faut aussi peut être une
justice plus ferme des mesures plus
fermes aussi à apporter sur certains
dossiers certains caressent que des fois
en tant qu'élu local vous êtes un peu
aussi désabusé sur certains dossiers
elle sauf que pour qu'ils aient justice
il faut déjà qu'ils aient avant lui une
une action de la police
et donc c'est la première étape qu'il
faut déjà qu'on règle c'est qu'on est
les forces de police qui puisse
intervenir au moment où les délits sont
constatés parce que c'est ça aussi qui
sert d'exemple plus que les peines qui
sont appliquées on peut appliquer ce qui
sert d'exemple c est ce qu on a une
réactivité des forces de police sur un
territoire philippe benassaya à présent
votre regard sur cette question de la
sécurité et peut-être aussi des
problématiques tant que maire sur
lesquels des fois vous êtes démunis ont
en général il ya très peu de lien entre
la question sociale et la sécurité en
général quand on met le
la question sociale comme paravent c'est
bien évidemment pour être dans le déni
la vraie question de la sécurité dans
notre pays c'est le sentiment d'impunité
cas dans ce pays aujourd'hui les punks
qui ne sont pas respectées et le déni
dont je parlais aujourd'hui la sécurité
c'est la première des libertés
donc il faut pas tourner autour du pot
et d'aller chercher des réflexions
sociales il faut voir exactement ce que
peuvent faire à la fois l'état et à la
fois les locaux parce que j'estime que
la sécurité n'est pas le leur n'est pas
qu'une question du haut c'est aussi
également la question des élus locaux
j'ai trouvé quelques exemples dans le
canton et dans la ville j'ai déjà fait
pas mal j'ai déjà lancé pas mal de
projets comme défendu supervision urbain
affronter la furie nous le développement
de la vidéoprotection c'est très utile
aujourd'hui si on n'a pas ces moyens sur
le terrain on n'arrive pas à régler les
problèmes de sécurité
si on n'arrive pas à développer j'espère
que quand je serai l'assemblée nationale
j'essaierai d'y déposer des propositions
de loi sur ce sujet s'il faudrait
développer davantage les polices
municipales il faut arrêter d'être un
petit peu dans l'angélisme du tout
régaliens donc quand on sait que ce
regalia et tentera maigrir de plus en
plus que l'état n'a plus les moyens et
que les locaux s'organisent pour pouvoir
organiser leur propre circularité sur
leur propre territoire attendre l'état
pour régler un problème dans l'eure où
dans la minute donc je pense qu'il y a
après partenariat qui doit s'effectuer
entre communes agglomérations et l'état
voilà le reste moi je trouve que nous
sommes dans un pays où il ya une
certaine pensée unique et qui essaie de
tourner autour du pot et de et de nier
la réalité du terrain et des quartiers
pense qu'il faut voir la réalité comme
elle est il y à vrai problème de
sécurité dans ce pays il ya un problème
de langage aussi alors c'est vrai que le
mont sauvagement hérisse les uns
hennerici pas les autres moi ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup la dianétique
s'est passé pas moins culture politique
ma culture politique c'est plutôt de
savoir comment sur le terrain on peut
s'organiser pour pouvoir régler ses
problèmes de sécurité chs estime que les
acteurs locaux que les maires près les
conseillers départementaux ou autres
peuvent agir pour pouvoir régler ces
problèmes très rapide
olivier galland debout la france vous
pensez vous aussi qu'il ya une problème
de sécurité
jeffrey réagi ensuite laurent morin qui
souhaitaient s'exprimer tout en sachant
que vous aurez assez peu de temps on
avait déjà beaucoup d' avance olivier
galland pour bigard ya un grave problème
de sécurité dans notre pays par monsieur
benassaya et proche des habitants de
bois d'arcy moi je le vois sur saint cyr
l'école en général oui oui sur sortir
l'école il ya des quartiers comme le
mien où ça se passe très bien en fait
moi je fais pas de la politique pour mon
jardin ou pas ce qui se passe à côté de
chez moi je fais du phénomène plus
général
qu'est ce qu'on entend des tirs de
mortier dans la vie le des rodéos des
choses comme ça la politique les gens ne
les arrête pas parce qu'ils aient des
maisons des consignes pour ne pas les
arrêter un pour ne pas blesser les gens
qui pilotent des engins des passants et
puis ces gens là ils passent en justice
ou pas parce que des fois le faut ça
s'arrête un simple rappel à la loi
et le lendemain matin ils sont de
nouveau dans lordonnance cité en disant
à leurs copains bien voyez je suis à
kericho accueille donc à la police
effectivement il ya besoin de moyens
plus importants
une fois que la police elle a fait son
travail il faut que la justice elles
interviennent
parce que si ce sont toujours les mêmes
que la police arrête c est quand même
une dépense de moyens un petit peu
inutile alors après on a parlé de
monsieur sarkozy effectivement si
sarkozy il avait supprimé la double
peine a donc quelques parts et
catastrophes de cette chose là parce que
ce sont toujours les mêmes qui relaie
qui reviennent ensuite une fois que les
clés les sanctions sont décidées il faut
qu'elle soit appliquée on entend
régulièrement parler de gens qui font
l'obligation tube qui sont sous le coup
d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire et qui déambulent dans nos
rues en faisant des agressions si la loi
était appliquée et si vous avez quitté
la france ne serait pas en train de s'en
prendre à nos concitoyens dont il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire je reviendrai
juste sur la mutilation des chevaux
parce que c'est un terme qu'on a on
appris hier
alors est ce que c'est vous sera j'm'en
si vous pouvez voyons où barbare alors
on sait plus quel terme utilisé
la situation dégénère de jour en jour
laurent morin responsable rassemblement
national vous passe la parole également
mais seulement une trentaine de secondes
si vous voulez avoir du temps ensuite
pour pouvoir conclure sur la dernière
séquence de l'émission vous à dire sur
la sécurité je vais essayer d'être bref
je peux pas laisser passer ce qu'a dit
madame grand gambe sur sur la police
elle semble faire porter la
responsabilité sur les policiers je
crois je crois vraiment que si le bât
blesse c'est du côté de la justice qui
ont pas compris hein parce que c'est
exactement le contraire que j'ai dit ok
je pense que les policiers les forces de
l'ordre ont très bien pour eux aussi et
ça depuis des années d'ailleurs parce
que vous êtes vous êtes plutôt
l'incarnation le parti socialiste d'un
laxisme que nous payons que nous payons
aujourd'hui les forces de l'es6 l'abbé
brad vous vous même vous auto persuadé
de choses que je n'ai pas dit mais a
encore quelque chose que tu hantes à
nantes a été assassiné un individu qui
est un individu qui a bénéficié d'une
lentille d'une libération anticipée
là le problème n'est pas un problème
puisque j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'il fallait
plus de forces de l'ordre donc
excusez moi je peux pas être plus clair
laurent moreau si vous souhaitez vous a
répondu je remercie vous souhaitez
anciaux n'est sûr sur une idée
concernant la sécurité et là je voulais
dit vous aviez pris beaucoup d'avancé
sur le reste vous m'aviez dit vouloir
prendre du temps sur le reste tant pis
pour ces sujets le ces sujets là donc
allez-y
mais très clair en nos propositions
parce que j'avais pas mal de choses à
dire effectivement sur la sur la
sécurité mais nos propositions c'est
d'abord d'en finir avec le laxisme
judiciaire je viens de le dire
d'ex culte et d'expulser les délais en
des délinquants pardon et les criminels
étrangers d'augmenter le nombre de
places en prison
en construisant de nouvelles structures
de rétablir les peines planchers et
d'habiter la majorité à 16 ans carlus à
présent pour la république en mars et
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
vous portez tout de même la voix du
gouvernement puisque vous êtes le
candidat de la république en mars
votre regard et vos réponses éventuel
alors déjà me voir et saluer
l'initiative de l'intérieur qui est de
vouloir diffuser plus régulièrement des
chiffres concrets sur la délinquance
pour pouvoir se baser sur la réalité
passe pour façonner des voix senti on
voit beaucoup de polémiques basée sur
des faits nucléaire
alimentée régulièrement un couvent
sauvagement les rodéos les règlements de
compte les squats etc
il ya toujours un épisode différents
alimenter un peu par par une forme de
plus ils sont politiques
moi je pense qu il faut prendre un peu
de hauteur faut vraiment traiter une
étude est plutôt que de faire de la
basse politique répond à la priorité
quand j'entends parler aux habitants la
circonscription pour une partie de ses
habitants effectivement bien il ya un
sentiment d'insécurité au quotidien mais
en parlant sécurité de proximité
ils en ont marre de voir des jeunes fin
des rodéos à moto en bas de leur
immeuble
il parle d'effectifs de police
insuffisant quand effectivement il
appelle la police ce soit et qu'ils ne
peuvent pas se déplacer parce qu'il a
pas assez d'équipement pour eux c'est un
vrai problème
quelle réponse on apporte 7 sur 20 des
cas on corrige ce qui a été fait depuis
des années et qui a était délétère
j'aime toujours entendre parler là la
droite de sécurité vous savez la
sécurité pour un peu l'afrique mccain de
la droite quoi ce qu'on parle de plus qu
en font le moins et ils ont supprimé des
milliers de postes
ils ont réduit les moyens de celle de
proximité nous depuis depuis 2010 est on
l'a créé et 7000 postes seront créés
trois mille l'an prochain on a d'énormes
difficultés à concrétiser ses
recrutements sur le terrain pourquoi me
sert aucunement est difficile les gens
ne veulent plus de policiers parce que
c'est un métier dangereux c'est un
métier où on est de moins en moins bien
vu et qu'on me son travail sont
compliquées nokia est un an de travail à
faire pour valoriser le travail le
rendre plus attractif
on va généraliser les caméras piétons
par exemple qui vont sécuriser fortement
le travail des policiers
en donnant des éléments de preuve
intervention qui qui réalise et ça passe
aussi par une réponse pénale qui est
plus adapté alors je n'aime pas le terme
le sévère se le dise pas là pour être
sévère elle est là pour être juste et
pour être juste il faut qu'elle soit
rapide pouvait pas attendre plusieurs
mois avant d'avoir une réponse pénale et
donc il faut aussi les choses qui n'est
ce qu'on devine bien les salariés votre
temps de paroles s'envolent
en deux mots pour conclure pour moi je
propose
accélère la mise en place de mesures
d'éloignement pour prendre les caïds les
sortir de leurs quartiers dans voyage au
bout de la france où ils ont plus de mal
et on casse les bandes on casse les au
point comme ça et ça s'inscrit je mange
comme place contrairement à se qualifier
bien ça ya pour moi l'action sociale est
forcément liés à la sécurité
on peut pas faire de la sécurité en ne
faisant que la répression
il faut aussi lutter contre l'échec
scolaire former les gens pour qu'ils
travaillent et pour qui sa part de
conclure sinon sur la dernière
thématique n'aurait pas temps de
conclure kamal ben ma roue je vous
écoute à présent concernant les
questions de sécurité
vous qui résidé sur trappe alors
commencer par un constat personnel de ce
site est devenu plus violent parce que
le marché du travail devenu plus violent
les renoncements successifs des
gouvernements depuis une cinquantaine
d'années notamment face à l'euro ont
laissé prospérer un chômage de masse et
ont perverti l'école de la république en
lui faisant renoncer à former des
citoyens
on ne formait que des travailleurs
corvéables à merci c'est là la violence
première son nom à la mère de toutes les
baies lance de notre société notre
nation et c'est à dire que bien sûr que
la sûreté comme ça je préfère l'appeler
en référence à la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen est un droit
absolument fondamental le droit tout
simplement de rester en vie le droit à
de la préservation de l'intégrité
physique et morale
personne ne peut discuter cela mais
personne non plus ne peut ne peut
ignorer que quelque part c'est d'abord
le poisson pourrit par la tête
c'est d'abord dans ça se passe comment
s'étonner par exemple de la violence
attribuée je met les pieds dans le plat
aux jeunes des cités comme disent les
médias si leur première employeur c'est
le trafic de drogue
comment s'étonner que les plus
désespérés d'entre eux peuvent tomber
dans une dérive islamiste terme plus que
contestable et comment ne pas s'insurger
du coup contre les agitations temps d'un
côté des prétendus islamistes et de
l'autre des prétendus nationaliste dès
lors que on s'affronte autour d'un
fantasme de l'âge d'or
pour les uns le khalife pour les autres
roi soleil on est dans une confusion
totale dans la mesure où on ne sait même
plus attribués par se demander enfin
considérer que tout cela repose d'abord
sur un contrat social sur l'idée qu'on
se fait d'une société et notamment de
ceux qui la dirigent les réponses à
apporter une refondation du civisme
républicain il est plus que temps de
refonder un contrat social parce que ces
institutions en train de s'effondrer et
que s'il ya une grande oubliée dans tout
cela c'est d'abord la république et ses
principes
patrick planque à présent sur la
sécurité à tout d'abord moi je tiens à
protester quand même vivement contre les
propos de monsieur morin et mathieu
gallant qui sont alors dans leurs rôles
1 mais qui assimile immigration et
délinquance c'est inadmissible la
véritable aujourd'hui la véritable la
véritable insécurité pour bon nombre de
gens c'est la perte de son boulot c'est
le chômage c'est une insécurité sociale
en réalité est toute la propagande et
tout le
les discussions de la droite de
l'extrême droite sur la sécurité la
surenchère qui mette vis-à-vis du
gouvernement pour essayer de faire
passer ça comme la première
préoccupation des gens c'est aussi une
façon pour camoufler les vrais problèmes
sociaux les vrais problèmes aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont oui effectivement on n'a pas
de boulot on sait pas ce que va devenir
nos gamins il ya personne pour les
encadrer ya personne il ya plus de
services publics dans les dents dans les
villes il ya plus tout un tas de tout un
tas 2 de service qui fait que qui rend
la vie des gens corrects ivan lins vie
qui rend la vie des gens dans les
quartiers dans les cités correct et ça
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai problème c'est
un vrai problème et s'est essayé à mon
sens le vrai la vraie priorité qu'il
faudrait avoir
olivier galland vous avez un petit peu
de retard sur le temps de parole si vous
souhaitez répondre oui
les étrangers ne sont pas un problème
parce que vous pourriez dire sur le
marché samedi matin samedi matin moi
j'ai discuté avec lui dame est arrivée
en france à l'âge de trois ans et ce qui
m'a interpellée chez elle c'était sa
fille et sa fille était en train de se
balader dans la rue en disant ah et
voilà et donc on a parlé éducation avec
cette dame les questions qu'elle se
posait le jeu allez-vous c'était qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec les enfants qui
regardent trop la télé voilà on parle
pas de délinquance on parle juste
d'éducation d'une éducation basique je
vais faire avec cette dame comme je
l'aurais fait avec d'autres donc il ya
un problème de d'étrangers vous pas
étranger et enfin vous avez dit tu vois
c'est tout philippe benassaya maire de
déballeurs si je n'ai pas été visée par
ce qu'a dit plan c ça je crois
personne n'a parlé d'immigration si vous
comparez mais ça m'étonne pas l'extrême
mon jeu vous êtes obsédé par
l'immigration et par ces sujets là
personne n'a parlé ça on a parlé de
social en matière de sécurité ces mêmes
grands comme d'arcade en parler je crois
moi je parle surtout de décentralisation
de la sécurité en effet de redonner des
pouvoirs aux élus locaux et aux acteurs
locaux pour essayer de régler les
problèmes cités sécurité au plus près au
plus près du terrain
je vois pas pourquoi vous mettez ce
sujet sur le sur le tapis bien
évidemment pour essayer encore une fois
de faire de la petite politique
politicienne et d'assimiler les uns avec
les autres
essayez de marham à un débat à la fois
raisonnable et et à ses objectifs sur ce
sujet sans forcément sans forcément
quand il du doigt les uns les autres
alors c'était juste que je voulais dire
sur le problème de la sécurité mais
c'est comme l'environnement il est dans
mon pays il faut il faut il faut des
polémiques sur des sujets qui devraient
rassembler patrick lang
si vous souhaitez répondre s'il
m'entendait oui c'est pas moi qui ai
parlé de l'immigration c'est quand même
pas moi qui ai parlé de reconduite à la
frontière
c'est pas moi qui ai parlé de
délinquance avec des gens qui va falloir
reconduire à la frontière une fois qu'on
les a arrêtés c'est pas moi qui ai parlé
de ça c'est bien c'est bien monsieur
morale mathieu gallant donc ne moi je ne
fais pas des polémiques si vous tenez
absolument être à être associé à 7 à
cette idée vous pouvez je pense que vous
êtes d'accord sur un certain nombre de
point d'ailleurs à mon avis vu les
politiques que vous avez menées au
gouvernement et ailleurs bien évidemment
vous êtes d'accord sur cette situation
problème aujourd'hui c'est un problème
oui c'est un problème c'est un problème
aujourd'hui le vrai problème c'est la
perte de son boulot c'est un problème de
chômage c'est un problème d'éducation et
c'est un problème de manque de
professeurs dans les écoles de personnel
encadrant et c'est oui c'est ça le vrai
problème aujourd'hui qui préoccupent la
population jour passe la parole vous
avez un peu plus de retard avant que
nous passions en suite aux conclusions
pour équilibrer aussi le temps entre les
uns et les autres ce sera l'occasion
mais si vous souhaitez encore vous
exprimer sur la question de la sécurité
sur ce qui a pu être dit bien compris je
veux pas être la personne en général on
comprend pas ce qu'on me dit dans ces
cas là vous dites ça aux autres
candidats vous dit ça s'est passé comme
critique puisque vous avez entendu des
choses que je n'ai pas dit
donc je n'ai pas fait de bien outre le
social et la question de sécurité j'ai
dit qu'il fallait plus le forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain et que c'était un
problème de service public c'est simple
j'ai et que ont rejoint les
problématiques de service public en
général dans ce pays c'est à dire qu'on
a cassé les services publics dans
l'abdomen dans le domaine de la sécurité
comme dans les eaux est un des points on
est en désaccord
normal qu'on soit en désaccord c'est sur
votre vision qui est plutôt local moi je
pense que c'est un sujet régalien et
qu'il faut que l'état soit armé pour
traiter ces questions là en
collaboration bien sûr avec les élus
mais c'est d'abord le rôle de lucas
voilà ce que j'ai dit contactez nous
allons faire un dernier tour de table
pour ce débat chacun des candidats va
s'exprimer dans l'ordre de
l'enregistrement des candidatures en
préfecture selon la liste qui nous a été
transmise avec forcément un temps
différent pour les uns et les autres
pour équilibrer olivier galland on va
commencer avec vous
vous avez deux minutes pour pouvoir
conclure et comme ça chacun pour être
entre 9 9 minutes 30 de temps de parole
au cours de cette émission olivier galon
commence donc avec vous je voulais dit
vous avez au maximum deux minutes pour
vous exprimer
pour conclure ou ensuite abordé aussi un
sujet que vous le souhaitez c'est votre
carte blanche je m'écoutais je vais
faire les deux
dans les sujets de la campagne vers les
luttes contre les incivilités lutte
contre les trafics et contre eux et
contre la fraude en particulier la
fraude sociale qu'il y en a qui vont
faire leurs dents un tollé dans votre
dans les propos la civic en a parlé
les détritus les rodéos les poubelles
qui brûlent il ya également des gamins
qui ont blessé par balle ça c'est la
suite il y en a qui s'est fait fracasser
des nains il ya très longtemps donc à un
moment où il faut arrêter les trafics
alors on a beau dire ce qu'on ce qu'on
veut chic dans certains quartiers de
saint cyrille ont pignon sur rue à les
trafiquants de drogue de la police
intervient régulièrement dans son
couloir avec avec l'ordre sur leur table
et puis les comptes entre dans certaines
cités et il faut montrer la cazine ses
papiers parce que et contrôler ce que
font les invite donc les citoyens ils
ont ils ont en marre de cette situation
et c'est vraiment une préoccupation ne
nie pas que le chômage c'est pas une
préoccupation mais au quotidien
cette insécurité c'est vraiment un sujet
et je pense que la justice doit agir je
suis désolé monsieur semer les exemples
qu'on a pu avoir comme nabil bey qui
libérait 13013 mille prisonniers il ya
pas très longtemps
et puis notre nouveau garde des sceaux
qui jouent au baby foot c'est ne sais
pas c'est parce qu'on attende
après moi je voudrais vous parler des
fraudes
or ce c'est un sujet que conquis ce
n'est beaucoup en avant il ya un rapport
parlementaire qui arrivait et côté
debout la france
on assiste là dessus qu'on pense qui a
une fraude massive et organisée à la
sécurité sociale de manière générale et
des gens qui bénéficient de prestations
sécurité sociale alors qu'ils n'y ont
pas droit
il ya des gens qui bénéficient de
retraites alors qu'ils sont décédés
depuis des années
voilà c'est de l'argent c'est de la
fraude c'est de l'argent qui serait
mieux utilisé avec nos concitoyens qui
ont
elles ont besoin donc voilà six mois
j'étais à l'assemblée j'organiserai
quand même une lutte contre ces fraudes
peut le faire on peut on peut vérifier
que carey vivante ou pas en passant à
laurent morin pour le rassemblement
national vous avez une minute pour
conclure et mon appel à la mobilisation
pour ce scrutin mobilise traditionnelle
bien sûr mais également mobilisation des
abstentionnistes
trois bonnes raisons pour pour se rendre
aux urnes
d'abord défendre son droit fondamental
en se mobilisant le droit de potes
sanctionné comme je l' ai déjà dit les
responsables de l'effondrement de notre
pays et je le rappelle le parti
socialiste les républicains et la
république en marche qui ont tous été au
pouvoir et qui portent tous une part de
responsabilité dans l'effondrement
actuel de nos pays et enfin la troisième
raison c'est permettre une meilleure
représentativité à l'assemblée nationale
il est anormal
le premier parti de france celui qui est
arrivé au second tour des
présidentielles jeter un pont européenne
mais que six députés sur 577
le client aux électeurs de rétablir
cette injustice et de préparer la france
d'après pierre lui c'est à vous pouvoir
la république en marche vous avez une
trentaine de secondes maximum pour
conclure un accord je m'adressais du
goût directement aux électeurs et je
leur dire voilà si vous faites confiance
le 27 septembre dont la députée qui est
proche de vous qui connaît votre
quotidien qui prend le train tous les
matins pour aller travailler comme vous
et qui sera dévoué à son mandat parce
qu'on peut pas faire autre chose en même
temps on peut pas avoir un autre mandat
surtout si cet autre mandat rémunéré
outils et sera réputé qui sera attentif
à l'ensemble des citoyens sera pas
uniquement le député une partie de la
population ou d'une ville à laquelle clé
une attache particulière sera présent
auprès de vous dans l'ailé des
permanences régulières est toujours à l
écoute
ils ont la corde défendre le projet que
je défends depuis toujours
c'était un style une réplique pour tous
et qui donne sa chance à tout le monde
chacun d'entre vous chacun de vos
enfants
voté le 27 septembre marouf à présent
avec le collectif et république par
raison vous avez deux minutes pour
aborder votre carte blanche pour
conclure votre séquence dans le débat ce
soir
merci monsieur un jeu
je suis convaincu que la vème république
va s'effondrer pour les mêmes raisons
que la quatrième le régime des partis je
suis un citoyen hors parti mon seul
honneur et d'être citoyen de me lancer
dans une bataille cilic à la défense de
pour la défense de mes concitoyens de
lego et de la république je ne m'ont
élections ne modifiera pas la majorité
actuelle à l'assemblée nationale bien
entendu alors si au moins je veux
incarner ce maillon entre les
institutions et les citoyens notamment
en traquant tous les manquements des
services publics sur le terrain qui
cause sans doute plus grand tort aux
citoyens les plus modestes et et même
vos autres et si je peux faire entendre
une autre voix qui en fait très ancienne
qui est celle que nous avons tous appris
à l'école qui est celle des principes de
la république qui est que l'idée du
contrat social dès qu'il a pu être
défendus ou sohu et par la révolution
française
à mon avis est toujours d'actualité vive
la république et vive la france patrick
planque à présent pour lutte ouvrière
vous aussi vous avez deux minutes à
présent le monde du travail s'appauvrit
et la société recul des années en
arrière pour qu'une minorité
capitalistes continuent de faire son
beurre et c'est encore ce grand patronat
et son système que le gouvernement aide
en l'arrosant 2 milliards notamment à
travers le plan de relance
face aux attaques de la bourgeoisie face
à la pauvreté à la rapacité des trains
des lébous rejoint les travailleurs
n'ont pas d'autre choix que de se
défendre
il faut qu'ils agissent collectivement
et se dote d'un plan de combat car le
grand patronat ne connais que le rapport
de force il faut travailler moins pour
travailler tous sans perte de salaire
il faut augmenter les salaires par les
marges ni les dividendes il faut le
contrôle des salariés sur les milliards
d'euros distribués au grand patronat
et cet argent doit servir à créer des
emplois et augmenter les salaires
il faut se battre il faudra dans ces
élections
votez bien évidemment pour faire
entendre le camp des travailleurs et
pour terminer je voulais juste vous dire
que
demain soir réunion vendredi soir une
réunion publique se tiendra à trappes à
la salle de la maison des familles voilà
à 19 heures vous pouvez venir nombreux
mais à présent philippe benassaya mais
les républicains de bois d'arcy
également engagée dans ce scrutin alors
je rappelle que vous nous avez rejoint
en cours d'émission donc forcément vous
aurez un tout petit peu moins de moins
de temps de parole à l'issue de
l'émission mais vous pouvez conclure en
2 minutes environ
oui merci c'est vrai que c'est un peu de
ma faute mais je ne me suis pas beaucoup
exprimé mais je suis arrivé en retard
donc il n'y est pour rien mais j'aurais
voulu quand même un petit peu faire des
choses que j'aurais pu dire peut-être en
navire la production de ce débat d'abord
pourquoi on vote on voit que pour les
législatives partielles
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que notre
circonscription n'a plus de députés
d'abord parce que la députée heures
marche et une ministre de la ville et
que l a immédiatement démissionné son
poste pour empêcher son suppléant de 2,6
g pour les problèmes juridiques
judiciaires qu'il qu'il connaît c'est
quelque chose d'à peu près inédit sous
la vème république
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ça ça
je pense qu'il faut revenir un peu à la
loi il ya eu un avant et un après qu
vide je pense et je pense que pendant
cette crise due qu'au guide les
habitants de 3,6 reconstruction se sont
rendus compte que ce qu'ils aient le le
travail ceux qui ont obtenu des
résultats
ceux qui ont fait leurs preuves ce sont
les élus de terrain et c'est eux qui ont
travaillé pendant ce temps là je pense
qu'il veut la période des députés un peu
hors sol qui n'avaient pas la
circonscription je pense que c'est
terminé je pense que les français n'en
veulent plus de ça ils veulent des gens
qui sont entrés dans leur territoire qui
connaissent leur ville et qui
connaissent les limites de la
circonscription toutes les villes
pateline toutes les villes les villes
des cantons de cette circonscription et
les villes qui appartiennent à
différentes communautés d'agglomération
je pense que c'est ça l'essentiel
aujourd'hui en france je pense que les
habitants
les français veulent des députés nos
boxeurs mais des tubes députés ancré
dans leur territoire des députés qui
connaître la réalité des députés qui ont
servi les français sur le terrain
pendant les différentes crises
sanitaires économiques ou sociales qu'on
a connue c'est ça qu'il faut à mon avis
promouvoir de notre pays un joli fermont
l'assemblée nationale et au parlement en
général ce sont des élus du terrain et
c'est ça qui est important aujourd'hui
pour notre pays n'est pas dénué des gens
qu'on a chuté au dernier moment pour
faire des pourcentages ou des voix c'est
à l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est de bien
connaître les sujets du terrain et de
les faire remonter
c'est aussi cela que je voudrais faire
je serai j'espère députés c'est-à-dire
de faire remonter les bonnes pratiques
de ce terrain là les élus locaux ont
lancé des projets ils ont obtenu des
résultats faut les entendre on les a pas
toujours entendus parce qu'au début on
les a méprisé mais quand il s'agit de
les appeler le camp la crise et est
forte et on a toujours répondu présent
et puis il ya des sujets on n'a pas
abordé peut-être vous avez abordé
pendant que j'étais pas là je ne sais
pas et je pense que la question de la
liberté dans ce pays très importantes et
notamment la liberté d'expression
il me semble aujourd'hui que cette
liberté menacée elle et menacé un petit
peu partout et j'espère que nous allons
pouvoir revenir à ce qu'a fait le sel de
la france qui a fait la france c'est à
dire notre liberté
et puis je voudrais aussi dire que je
serai à députés qui sera proche des
chefs d'entreprise des artisans des
commerçants des salariés pour les
entendre et pour être leur porte voix et
pour être le porte-voix de ses forces
vives du terrain voilà l'objectif
sandrine gang vous êtes actuellement
première adjointe à trappes commune de
cette 11e circonscription vous présenter
sous les couleurs génération notamment
mais aussi europe écologie qui vous
soutient et vous avez deux minutes pour
conclure j'aurais voulu parler de
l'école parce qu'il me semble que dans
la période
le décrochage scolaire avec la crise
qu'on a vécu est un vrai sujet mais
c'est quand même revenir sur la question
de l'environnement parce que je pense
qu'elle est aujourd'hui centrale cette
question là et c'est pas une question de
cadre de vie c'est une question profonde
c'est un modèle de société je pense
qu'il faut qu'on change de modèle de
société et les impacts sur le secret
circonscription ils sont énormes
on le voit on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de
la réalité de ce que vit notre
circonscription avec des problématiques
qui sont différentes d'un canton à
l'autre mais aussi des choses qui sont
communes la question des transports la
saturation de cet espace que nous avons
en commun qui fait que c'est un devenu
invivable quand beaucoup de gens comment
trouver de ce problème là comme on
développe les transports en commun on a
des propositions dans ce sur ce sujet
comment on lutte contre les pollutions
qui sont des pollutions sonores qui sont
aussi des pollutions
des nuisances en termes atmosphérique
qui ont les impacts sur la santé de nos
concitoyens
comment on préserve les poumons d'air de
nos villes on a un certain nombre de
lieux à protéger on a beaucoup mis de
béton dans l'aube il que ce soit à saint
cyr à bois d'arcy même à trappes
on a construit parfois parce que c'était
nécessaire mais on a parfois aussi trop
construire certains endroits donc il
faut remettre de la nature dans tout ça
et les gens aujourd'hui en sont
conscients ils ont vraiment pris
conscience je crois que il y à un modèle
a changé et c'est pour ça que les
questions à la fois en amont on a
développé un slogan qui est notre futur
sera écologique et sociale parce que
dans mon ami ce sont les deux sujets
majeurs qui sont devant vous merci à
vous d'avoir participé à cette émission
on revoit à l'antenne les temps de
parole respectifs qui s affiche
je rappelle pendant ce temps que le
scrutin législatif se déroulera pour le
premier tour dès ce dimanche 20
septembre il concerne les électeurs des
communes de bois d'arcy elancourt
fontenay le fleury la verrière le mesnil
saint denis saint cyr l'école et trappes
et puis je rappelle enfin que onze
candidats se présentent sur la cette
circonscription la 11e dans le cadre de
cette législative partielle et on va
revoir la liste complète certains ne
pouvais pas être avec nous mais ils sont
également engagés merci encore d'avoir
participé avec des conditions techniques
particulières puisque je rappelle pour
les téléspectateurs ne pouvons percevoir
à l'ensemble des candidats en plateau
pour une question de respect des
gestes-barrières merci en tout cas nous
avoir suivis merci aux candidates et
candidats et on se retrouve bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]